I hear you now often the same here
because I tried drawing them in on the
same diagram and it just gets very
confusing all from the psych ER I'm
going to draw to force resolution
diagrams what which corresponds to a
name and one which corresponds to be
okay and then much like weed in your
projectile motion are going to work out
what's the horizontal what's the
vertical component okay so here's what
it looks like look like this is under
par [ __ ] okay so wonderful let's do ap
first Capeside knowing what about
anything so ap looks like this there's a
and there's paper okay I've got a box
around here just like I have your
projectile motion and you can see
there's going to be a horizontal part I
like to draw here because it's acting on
the particle and then there's a vertical
part here okay now I know that this
angle up in the corner is 30 degrees so
because this is a AP over here this is
the tension in the string right the
tension in the string it's fully in that
way so that the thin doesn't fall down
okay so if i call this like t 1 ok for
tension 1 i'm going to have a horizontal
component and a vertical component so
i'm going to call them y and x but i'm
gonna have a lot of ensemble x 1 and x 1
okay so how am I going to work out what
each of these parts is knowing that
that's 30 degrees we're going to do ok
so I'm going to use signing cause if you
remember but vertical things in hammer
kick in this top triangle right side 30
is going to be opposite on hypotenuse
right why one on t1 so just rearranging
this is going to be t1 times so sine
theta which is a half right so this is
actually just
21 so excess okay that's fine what about
what's happening on Honor I guess I can
do 60 or i can just say hey you can just
use cosine things going 30 degrees here
because it's altered angles and angle of
depression and angle of elevation are
always going to be the same so if I said
cause 30 right cos 30 of course is so
there you go now keep in mind i don't
know what T what is I don't know how
much tension pulling along it I'm going
to find that out Lena okay all I'm doing
is trying to separate out the different
parts of vertical horizontal can you do
the same thing for the other string can
do it for BP well wanted to try and then
we'll see what kind of a own a picture
that we get together
I totally booked this room um we move
your partner you know you're doing
sooner or later so you can
okay let's do the photo of component
first because it's easier because you
already know something about vertical
component right in exactly the same way
as I did before this vertical component
is going to be t1 sign whatever yeah so
here I want to get T 2 sine alpha which
of course is 3 over 4 so far so good in
the same way I can do the horizontal one
but you need to think a little more
because you don't know what the other
side is what is this I'm going to be if
I've got note 41 what is this side going
to be it's going to be written seven
right because you can see if this is 3
over for eternity the square root of
sixteen minus nine which is set okay so
that's roots headed over there right
this is going to give you seven on four
times whatever force is going off in
that angle director okay so you can see
I've got forces going this way I've got
horses going upwards two of them this
one and this one and then what forces
going that way right two of them going
opposite direction and remember that
particle is so now I'm ready to do pi
sin got a whole lot of information here
you need to put it together back with
Newton's first of all right there
because this thing is not moving that
means that the net force is zero all
your horizontal bits are balanced and
all of your vertical it's one two and
three are also balance does that make
sense you can say it in a couple of
different ways I prefer to go back to
the definition of net force zero so i'm
going to say let's do um let's do would
your horizontal vertical first which did
i do before I didn't horizontal for us
because it's less of them
yes I have resolved the forces so now I
have everything that turns off up down
left right I don't have anything off at
angles anymore okay so therefore I can
deal with them just like a different
project on okay so let's do the
horizontal bit first there are only two
horizontal forces and when I add them up
they should have a net result of 0 okay
so you can see here I've got one over
here and one over here does that make
sense you happy with that now I could
use that as my equation but I happen to
know like look at where I'm going you
see I'm going to have to find both of
these tensions t1 and t2 so I've got two
variables here in one equation I'm going
to have to produce another equation out
of the vertical forces right so since i
know i'm heading towards solving
simultaneously rather than leave this
equation in this messy fall i'm going to
prepare it for the next step right now
for simultaneous equations we know two
main strategies how to solve some
equations what are they substitution and
elimination now just think for a second
we have even written the second equation
yet but which do you think just looking
at these numbers which do you think is
more likely to be useful I think
substitution is going to be more useful
elimination remember the way it works is
uh I've got a pair of coefficients here
and another pair coefficient here and I
just need to fiddle with them to make
them the same I don't want to fiddle
with these guys they look disgusting so
I might as well put in a little bit of
extra work let's take t1 the subject can
you make to you on the subject for me
get in terms of teacher